I don't want to start getting
announcement right now
controversial welcome to Sidetrack your
Sci-Fi TV and movie channel
[Music]
gateworld recently did a story that I
100 agree with and I want to give them
credit for getting this out there now I
don't have the best working relationship
with dial the gate and gateworld but I
have to give them credit for all the
hard work they do trying to promote and
get a Revival of my favorite show but
also to gateworld for this really
interesting story that got me thinking
do I want Stargate to be announced right
now or what I prefer
to wait a little longer just tell me the
minute we can send consent broke through
now 24 hour
Captain Carter and Colonial do not have
that long I'll give you half that no
sure it doesn't work that way 24 hours
best I can do
and you better get back to it look we
don't want an announcement on Stargate
right now we don't want an announcement
on anything we just want the studios the
Actors Guild and the writers guilt have
put their damn heads together and come
up with a fair agreement that
everybody's reasonably happy with but
actually right now that is the priority
and Stargate just isn't now I know what
you're gonna say
Jamie saying that Stargate isn't
important it's all you've talked about
for the last 18 months man well it's not
right now
I don't want a Stargate announcement
because I don't want the studios to try
to distract us from what's actually
important and they will
they will try to distract us with
announcements like this now as you know
I've said before what would they even
announce they can't write any scripts
they can't get any actors online and
signed on they can't do anything so what
would they even be announcing if they
did put a press release out saying that
we're going to do a new Stargate movie
or anything else it would just be an
attempt by the studios to distract and
the studios and the basically the guilds
are currently in a battle for public
opinion
if anything actually releasing the
statement whenever now saying that they
are going to be doing a Stargate movie
or TV series would work we would be
distracted because we would get excited
by that
but how much you want to bet if they did
release that statement it would have a
little byline
as soon as the strikes end as soon as
the writers and the actors come back to
us and we can thrash out a fair deal we
might do a Stargate series we might do
RoboCop we might do something else all
of the studios would be very tempted to
try to do that to try to capture some
public opinion they might also be trying
to kind of pretend that you know it's
business as usual when we know it really
really isn't
so I completely agree with the gate
World story I really wish we had a
closer relationship with gateworld and
dial the gate they don't want to because
we are on the same page with this and
lots of other things regarding Stargate
and in this case the writers and the
actors strike the actors and the writers
need our support because public opinion
really matters in this
if the studios get enough of us maybe
thinking that the writers and the actors
are wasting everyone's time then that
really takes a lot of the power away
from the writers and the directors who
have enough problems as it is with the
studios threatening to actually try to
outweigh them there's a game of chicken
going on here and the studios are hoping
that the writers and you know the large
majority of those actors that we've
never heard of will run out of money and
that will start demanding that The
Writers Guild and the
um stage Actors Guild start negotiating
again and they will not get as good a
deal
so we need to offer the actors and those
writers our support I am standing
shoulder to shoulder with gateworld and
I am saying we must do this
we must wait and if they do announce
Stargate we will obviously celebrate it
we will then talk about why the studio
has done it and let's be honest they'll
have only done it to try and pull a fast
one and we mustn't let them but where
are we at with Stargate is an
announcement possible well to be honest
announcement is always possible it's
possible at any point
but the truth about what's going on in
Hollywood right now means that there's
kind of a clean slate we don't know what
the studios are going to do in the past
when there's been strikes lots of
projects have ended up being canceled
and the Studio's blame the guilds for it
they will say we've had to cancel this
because the writers because of this
strike that we can't afford we've had to
cancel this show that you love because
of the actor strike and the amount of
money that costing us speaking to
somebody I know that works again in the
industry this is on his opinion but he
basically says look nothing safe
any project even if it's already filming
isn't safe and speaking to somebody else
they basically agree with that but also
have said look sometimes the studios
actually retaliate with projects they
will actually use the cancellation as a
weapon to either get back at writers
actors that they don't like or as a
almost a threat get back to work or all
of these things that you're working on
just won't exist when you come back
there's also an element that maybe some
of the actors or some of the writers
that are most vocal will be noticed by
the studios and their projects will be
in trouble
I hope that's not how the studios
actually think but I suspect it is
so the future of Stargate really is an
unknown right now I do think the studio
could use project like Stargate as a
weapon either to shift public opinion or
to actually
punish some of the writers and some of
the actors that are on strike right now
and that's the option we really don't
want because speaking to the guy that
again works in the industry he says look
what you don't want is a bunch of
Executives with nothing to do sitting
around and second guessing their
decisions we really don't want them
thinking we want them to make a decision
and for everyone to crack on and get
their jobs done
an executive with time in his hands is
not necessarily a good idea
tell me what you think do you actually
think the studios would use this as a
weapon do you agree that the actors and
the writers are in the right ear and
that they need our maximum support or do
we have some sympathy for the studios
coming off two years of covid
You could argue it but um
I'd love to know exactly what you think
so get in the comments if you are new to
the Channel please like subscribe hit
that Bell notification you know exactly
what to do also you can go to
patreon.com forward slash Sidetrack
where most of our new videos appear
first and for a small contribution each
month that really supports the channel
you get a free gift as well after three
months you get to see them without the
adverts as always please stay safe and
I'll see you next time